لقد مر عقد ونصف
منذ أن
وجهت المحكمة الجنائية الدولية أول لائحة اتهام إلى الرئيس السوداني السابق عمر حسن البشير بارتكاب
جرائم ضد الإنسانية وجرائم حرب
، وحتى قبل أشهر فقط عندما
تولى مجلس السيادة السلطة بعد
الإطاحة بالبشير.  بدا أن هذا خط أحمر
لم تكن الحكومة السودانية في أي
تكرار وجدت نفسها على
استعداد لتجاوزه ، لكننا نفهم من
المحادثات مع مصادر حكومية
أنه أصبح قاطعًا للصفقة بين
الحكومة الانتقالية في
الوسط والجماعات المتمردة في المنطقة التي لا تزال
متنازع عليها.  مناطق في أجزاء أخرى من
السودان يمثل الكثير منها أولئك الموجودين في
دارفور والذين تم استهدافهم كجزء من
حملة الإرهاب التي شنها البشير
حكومته في ذلك الجزء من
البلاد لأولئك الذين تحدثوا إليهم في
السودان ، لقد كانت لحظة عاطفية للغاية
و  صدمة للعديد من أولئك الذين
سمعوا هذا للمرة الأولى ، ما
زلنا نفتقر إلى التفاصيل بشأن اللغة
التي نسمعها  من المقرر
أن يظهر البشير أمام المحكمة الجنائية الدولية سواء كان
ذلك في دين هاج أو
السودان ، ولم يتضح بعد أننا
نستمع إلى محاكم مختلطة قد تسمح
بمحاكمته في السودان ، وأخبرتنا مصادرنا
أن الحكومة السودانية
تعترف بذلك  لا يمتلك السودان
البنية التحتية لمحاكمة جرائم الحرب ، لكن من
المحتمل أن ينصب قضاة التحقيق
في محاكم مشتركة مع المحكمة الجنائية الدولية.
المهم هو أنه
أخيرًا بعد ثلاثة عقود من ثلاثة
عقود دموية بشكل لا يصدق ،
يبدو أن ديكتاتور السودان السابق يواجه أخيرًا نوعًا
من العدالة الحقيقية.